Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my new spider-man no way home video for that
big announcement that the sony president was
making in his interview with variety so we'll
break it all down there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs he basically confirms what their plans are
for crossing over the mcu with the sony spider-man
movies like venom 2 and what's going on with their
sinister six movies everything that they're doing
it was huge so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos we're
supposed to get the spider-man no way home trailer
in the next couple of weeks of course i'll
be doing videos for that the loki episodes
are starting really soon too i'll be doing full
episode videos for that just like i did for the
other marvel disney plus series speaking of tv
sony is also making some live-action spider-man
spin-off tv shows but that's completely separate
i'll do separate videos about that when we get
more details this is just about the future of
spider-man movies but within this interview
the sony president was also talking about all
the tobey maguire the andrew garfield stuff and
spider-man no way home in addition to what's going
on with venom 2 let there be carnage and obviously
the new craven movie and how they're handling
doing aaron taylor johnson craven and having
him is the mcu quicksilver at the same time so
we'll start with all the stuff that they confirm
first then i'll talk about some of the other
recent rumors because there were some pretty
big claims this past week that were seemingly
connected to what this sony president was saying
there were a couple really big things that he
did confirm but the first big thing is just the
actual basis for this whole interview with the
sony president or at least the way that variety
wrote their slam was how kevin feige and the
marvel people plan on crossing the mcu over
with sony's spider-man movies and that includes
venom 2 let there be carnage the morbius movie
the new craven movie that i just talked about with
aaron taylor johnson's version of the character
they're doing that spider-woman movie that we just
heard about a little while ago then spider-man
into the spider verse the animated films because
they were talking about using the live-action
actors as their versions of the spider-man
characters in that but that's just the tip of the
iceberg there's so much other stuff that they talk
about during this interview that's really cool
so the actual person that they were talking to
was the president of sony's live-action movies but
their conversation starts with a discussion of how
they cast aaron taylor johnson as craven in the
other movies that they were working on so the sony
president said that they cast him not because of
all his quicksilver avengers age of ultron marvel
stuff he says that they cast him because aaron
taylor johnson was starring in a movie with brad
pitt called bullet train that sony was making and
they just saw the dailies and thought that aaron
taylor johnson was awesome so then they cast him
as craven the funny thing the sony people said is
that they didn't even recognize him as quicksilver
like they didn't make that connection in their
head they just saw an actor that they thought
was great and then they had to do the research
on what other roles he done and say oh wow he
was just in avengers age of ultron but then their
conversation goes to spider-man specifically the
lack of spider-man in the sony movie so far like
the first venom movie so the sony president says
we don't really think of our 900 characters as
the spidey verse they control over 900 characters
because they have the rights to the spider-man
character he said we have a marvel universe they
call their spider-verse the sony universe of
marvel characters this the technical name for
their cinematic universe he says you know wait
until you see this next venom talking about venom
2 let there be carnage you don't miss spider-man
basically saying that there is spider-man in venom
2. so obviously the sony president isn't saying
exactly how spider-man appears during venom 2.
he just says that venom 2 will explain spider-man
inside the venom verse of movies the sony universe
of marvel characters then they sort of acknowledge
the complicated web that they're weaving to make
a spider-man pun between the mcu movies those
versions of the characters in all the sony movies
in those versions of the characters like michael
keaton's vulture from spider-man homecoming
showing up in the same white prison costume in the
morbius trailer but the sony president says we get
it there actually is a plan for crossing these
universes over i think now maybe it's getting a
little more clear for people where they're headed
and i think when spider-man no way home comes out
even more will be revealed so they're basically
saying that a lot of the crossing over of these
universes will be explained during spider-man no
way home more on that in the idea the multiverse
the spider-verse in a second but then the sony
president went on to talk about how the craven
movie with aaron taylor johnson's version of
the character who's also quicksilver in the mcu
avengers movies is the next piece in explaining
the way that the mcu will connect to the sony
spider-man movies but here's where they start
talking about all the andrew garfield and toby
maguire spider-man stuff in spider-man no way home
so the article goes on to say one of the worst
kept secrets in hollywood is that no way home
spiderman no way home will be diving headfirst
into the multiverse and incorporating characters
from sony's earlier spider-man movies starring
tobey maguire and andrew garfield alfred molina
for example told variety in april that he will
be digitally de-aged in spider-man no way home to
look like he did as the villain doctor octopus at
the end of 2004's spider-man 2. the implication
is that whatever happens in spider-man no way
home could allow for tom holland to live in sony's
marvel movies while also somehow being part of the
mcu but then they acknowledge that spider-man no
way home spider-man 3 is the last movie in sony
and marvel's sharing contract so i'll cover that
in a second too because this president at sony
was also saying some really cool stuff about his
relationship with kevin feige apparently they're
total bros but during that small segment talking
about the multiverse toby maguire andrew garfield
stuff there's a whole lot to unpack there so first
the sony president variety acknowledging that
they're already doing spider-verse related stuff
in spider-man no way home they don't come right
out and say tobey maguire and andrew garfield
themselves will show up in the movie so be careful
talking about that they were just referring to
the fact that they've confirmed they're doing
versions of the characters from those movies like
alfred molina confirmed that he's the same version
of doctor octopus and his story in spider-man no
way home begins the moment his body goes into the
river in spider-man 2. i actually did a separate
doctor octopus video a little while ago about that
so i'll link it down in the description he
pulled a bit of a tom holland mark ruffalo
and just completely gave away where his story
picks up and what's going on with his doctor
octopus during spider-man 3. but the whole thing
with the de-aging that's the exact same thing they
did with michael douglas michelle pfeiffer during
ant-man and the wasp obviously they de-aged them
a lot more than they're going to have to de-age
alfred molina he's not quite as old as they are
but doctor strange is a big crossover avengers
character during spider-man no way home and
the movie is coming out right before doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness the producers
on Wandavision said that they consulted with john
watts the director of spider-man 3 when they were
making Wandavision so pull out your vision memes
this whole conversation with the sony president
makes me feel like 100 percent they're just using
the multiverse as a way to say how the mcu is
connected with the movies like venom 2 the morbius
movie and how you can have aaron taylor johnson be
both quicksilver and craven the hunter at the same
time just alternate universe versions of all these
characters and when they say that venom 2 will
explain more of how spider-man himself fits into
the sony universe andy circus actually claimed
that during the venom 2 trailer the tom hardy's
venom and this version of the daily bugle
with the logo from the tobey maguire movies
this version of jay jonah jameson are not aware of
the existence of a spider-man yet at the beginning
of the movie which to me just screams venom 2
post-credits scene with a big spider-man reveal
like they have no idea that spider-man is
out there but that's just the beginning of
the movie and the idea is that they will slowly
discover him by the end of the movie and once we
see venom 2 and spider-man no way home that will
also explain toby mcguire's spider-man costume
in the morbius trailer there have been so many
theories about what's going on with that like
if it's a misdirect or if it's legit and it'll be
the exact same when the movie actually comes out
but the good news with that is that the morbius
movie is coming out in january just like a couple
weeks after spider-man no way home so we won't
have to wait that long to get the final piece of
the puzzle but mostly the sony president is saying
they'll explain how all this spider-verse stuff
is going to work in the future of tom hall and
spider-man crossing over with all these characters
in spider-man no way home and in venom 2. then
getting to the sinister six of it all the sony
president talked about the future of spider-man
and the mcu and future sinister six movies because
they still have to renew their sharing contract
with marvel right now so he said the great thing
is we have this very excellent relationship
with kevin talking about kevin feige there's
an incredible sandbox there to play with we want
those mcu movies to be absolutely huge because
that's great for us and our marvel characters at
sony and i think it's the same thing on their side
but we have a great relationship there's lots of
opportunities i think that are going to happen
one of those opportunities would be finally making
a movie about the sinister six they do acknowledge
the sinister six spin-off movie that sony tried
to make from the amazing spider-man franchise
like the end of the amazing spider-man 2 was meant
to set up a separate sinister six movie so they
had planned to make amazing spider-man 3 but also
separately make a sinister six movie like amazing
spider-man 3 was not going to be the sinister
six movie it was going to be something different
so the sony president goes on to say it's tough
because i think these projects are the kinds of
things we have to work on in the dark just
because of secrecy they're not ready until
they're ready he says craven is a good example
of that because they didn't rush it he said we
could have made that movie three years ago and the
reason why they waited till now was just to wait
until the script was good so according to variety
in the sony president they're basically confirming
what we already knew sony plans on renewing their
sharing contract with marvel again making more
spider-man movies with tom holland and yes they
do plan on making sinister six movies but they are
considering the sinister six movies to be separate
from the spider-man movies with tom holland that
they're also talking about like yes more tom
hall and spider-man more spider-man in the mcu
but also sinister six movies that also connect
with the mcu so here's where we get to the recent
rumors that are tied to what this sony president
was saying there were a lot of other sites this
past week that were reporting rumors that willem
dafoe's green goblin from the tobey maguire movies
would actually be the main villain of spider-man
no way home and that he would be assembling a
multiverse version of the sinister six team
made up of characters from the tobey maguire
spider-man movies like himself doctor octopus
andrew garfield amazing spider-man movies like
jamie foxx's electro and the mcu movies and
that the title of the movie no way home was
actually meant to be a reference to the sinister
six villains not having a way to get home to their
own universes like they're trapped in the mcu for
some reason which is supposed to be the connection
to doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness in
Wandavision with what scarlet witch is doing
implying that she's partially responsible for
creating some of the circumstances that lead
to the sinister six villains from the multiverse
getting trapped so that sounds like a whole lot to
unpack there if spider-man no way home suddenly
sounds like it's way too overstuffed with too
many characters what i actually think is going
on rumors and all is that most of these other
sinister six characters everyone is talking about
the sony president is talking about will only be
in the movie for a little while like it sounds
like based on what alfred molina is saying doctor
octopus and electro are main characters but if
this green goblin rumor is true then he'd probably
be just a post-credit scene cameo or a really
short cameo scene at the end of the movie
teasing a full-blown sinister six sequel down
the road but right now the rumor is that the
spider-man no way home trailer is releasing
sometime really soon tom holland's birthday
is next week so everyone is expecting them to do
something special next week whatever they do wind
up posting of course i'll do a video about it
my full loki episode videos will start posting
in the next two weeks too so make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
any of those there's a lot of really big stuff
coming up this summer this is just the beginning
congratulations andrew wright you're the giveaway
winner from my last big marvel video please email
me on the about page of my channel so i can
get your contact details everyone click here
for that last big spiderman no way home teaser
trailer video and easter eggs and click here for
my eternals trailer video for kit harrington's
black knight character and his future in the
avengers movies thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!